we've never seen this many cases of
covid the ons estimates more than three
million of us were infected last week
that's one in 15 people in england
little wonder there are plans to ease
pressure on the testing system next week
only those with covered symptoms will
have to book a pcr test the rest can
rely on lateral flows we have quite good
data from other sources to really
estimate the size of the epidemic and in
any event we only detect about a third
of the infections anyway based on ons
data but there is this problem of
capacity in the system that we could
overload
the pcr testing for very little gain in
a practical matter
clearly in a world with no restraints or
constraints and supply you keep doing
pcr but that's not the world we're in
the downside is it requires people to
faithfully upload results to test and
trace with around 1 million lateral flow
tests being reported daily 50 000 of
them positive officials believe the
approach will work to take pressure off
the system and those of us who use it
several experts have been calling for a
while for a shift away from pcr testing
to lateral flows and given for the vast
majority of us who've been boosted
omicron is quite a mild illness does
this latest step
mark another move towards living with
covid
officials say no removing the need for
pcr tests for asymptomatic illness and
now for travellers coming into the uk
is a temporary step while infections are
high they say okay
ladies but with vaccines holding their
own against omicron it's 2022 the year
everything changes i think that we're
seeing the end now
uh i really am we're just gonna have to
live with it we can't keep shutting down
shutting down every time there's an
outbreak and
a new variant comes along and everything
we have to live within the juice i don't
think it's gonna go away like fully um i
think as long as everyone gets
vaccinated we'll be able to live with it
without having as many deaths as we
previously did with vaccination and
infection rates at all time highs 95 of
us now have antibodies to covid that
makes a real difference we can look
forward i think to a much better second
half of 2022.
you know i'm also expecting the number
of deaths to be much lower in this wave
the early signs are that they will be
lower compared to previous waves so
hopefully you know the the fear that
we've all had over the last two years
and the death and suffering that we've
all seen over the last two years should
be
a thing of the past but of course we
have to get through the next few weeks
first
with omicron cases yet to peak across
the uk there could be some very hard
weeks to come
tom clark sky news